let us now study a very important
counting problem the problem of counting
combinations what is a combination we
start with a set of n elements and we're
also given a non negative integer K and
we want to construct or to choose a
subset of the original set that has
exactly K elements in different language
we want to pick a combination of K
elements of the original set in how many
ways can this be done
let us introduce some notation we use
this notation here which we read as n
choose K to denote exactly the quantity
that we want to calculate namely the
number of subsets of a given an element
set where we only count those subsets
that have exactly K elements how are we
going to calculate this quantity instead
of proceeding directly we're going to
consider a somewhat different counting
problem which we're going to approach in
two different ways
get two different answers compare those
answers and by comparing them we are
going to get an equation which is going
to give us in the end the desired number
the alternative problem that we're going
to use is the following we start as
before with our given set that consists
of n elements but instead of picking a
subset work what we want to do is to
construct a list an ordered sequence
that consists of K distinct elements
taken out of the original set so we
think of having K different slots and we
want to fill each one of those slots
with one of the elements of the original
set in how many ways can this be done
well we want to use the counting
principle so we want to decompose this
problem into a in two stages so what we
can do is to choose each one of the K
items that go into this list one at a
time
we first choose an item that goes to the
first position to the first slot having
used one of the items in that set we're
left with n minus 1 choices for the item
that can go into the second slot and we
continue similarly when we're ready to
fill the last slot we have already used
K minus 1 of the items which means that
the number of choices that we're going
to have at that stage is n minus K plus
1 at this point it's also useful to
simplify that expression a bit we
observe that this is the same as n
factorial divided by n minus K factorial
why is this the case you can verify that
this is correct by moving the
denominator to the other side and when
you do that you realize that you have
the product of all terms from n down to
n minus k plus 1 and then you have the
product of n minus K going all the way
down to 1
then that's exactly the product which is
the same as n factorial it's the product
of all integers from n all the way down
to 1 so this was the first method of
constructing the list that we wanted how
about the second method what we can do
is to first choose K items out of the
original set and then take those K items
and order them in a sequence to obtain
an ordered list so we construct our
ordered list in two stages in the first
stage how many choices we have that's
the number of subsets with K elements
out of the original set this number we
don't know what it is that's what we're
trying to calculate but we have a symbol
for it it's n choose K how about the
second stage we have K elements and we
want to arrange them in a sequence
that is we want to form a permutation of
those K elements this is a problem that
we have already studied and we know that
the answer is K factorial according to
the counting principle the number of
ways that this two-stage construction
can be made is equal to the product of
the number of ways number of options
that we have at the first stage times
the number of options that we have at
the second stage so this is one answer
for the number of possible ordered
sequences this is another answer of
course both of them are correct and
therefore they have to be equal and by
using that equality we can now find a
formula for this coefficient and choose
K simply by taking this K factorial
factor and sending it to the denominator
of that expression so by equating this
expression with that expression here we
find the final answer which is that the
number of choices and choose K is equal
to this expression here now this
expression is valid only for numbers
that make sense
so n can be any integer any non-negative
integer and K the only case that makes
sense would be case from 0 1 up to n you
may be wondering about some of the
extreme cases of that formula what does
it mean for and to be 0 or for k equal
to 0 so let us consider now some extent
of these extreme cases and make a sanity
check about this formula so this is the
formula that we have and that we want to
check the first case to consider is the
extreme case of n choose n what does
that correspond to out of a set with n
elements we want to choose a subset that
has n elements
there's not much of a choice here you
just have to take all of the elements of
the original set and put them in the
subset so the subset is the same as the
set itself so we only have one choice
here that should be the answer let's
check it with the formula the formula
gives us n factorial divided by n
factorial and then since K is equal to n
here we get 0 factorial is this correct
well it becomes correct as long as we
adopt the convention that 0 factorial is
equal to 1 we're going to adopt this
convention and keep it throughout this
course let us look at another extreme
case now the coefficient and choose 0
this time let us start from the formula
the formula tells us that this should be
n factorial divided by 0 factorial and
divided by n factorial
since the number K is equal to 0 using
the convention that we have this is
equal to 1 so this is again equal to 1
is it the correct answer how many
subsets of a given set are there that
have exactly zero elements well there's
only one subset that has exactly 0
elements and this is the empty set so
this explains this particular answer and
shows that it is meaningful and that it
makes sense now let us use our
understanding of those coefficients to
solve the somewhat harder problem
suppose that for some reason you want to
calculate this sum what is it going to
be one way of approaching this problem
is to use the formula for these
coefficients do a lot of algebra and if
you are really patient and careful
eventually you should be able to get the
right answer but this is very painful
let us think whether there's a clever
way a shortcut of
deigning this answer let us try to think
what this sum is all about this sum
includes this term which is the number
of zero element subsets this number
which is the number of subsets that have
one element and we keep going all the
way to the number of subsets that have
exactly n elements so we're counting
zero element subsets one element subsets
all the way up to n so what we're
counting really is the number of all
subsets of our given set but this is a
number that we know what it is the
number of subsets of a given set with n
elements is two to the N so by thinking
carefully and interpreting the terms in
this sum we were able to solve this
problem very fast something that would
be extremely tedious if we had tried to
do it algebraically for some practice
with this idea why don't you pause at
this point and try to solve the problem
of a similar nature